rated teen
hi guys i'm peter and the game direct on
dreadknot hey I'm Tim and I'm a game
designer dry not dreadnought is an
upcoming free to play area llamada
action game that focuses on capital
spaceship battles each spaceship
actually is fully customizable has
different ability modules different
officers and different weapon sets each
class has a very specific playstyle and
can then be customized towards your
preferences today we're going to play a
match of team elimination which is our
new and upcoming game mode in team
elimination each of the captains has
only one life once they go down with a
capital ship they can switch into a
fighter jet and support the team this
way so we will see that later I guess
yeah we're now in the orbit actually
discussing strategies so we are going
for a pretty aggressive strategy here
yes so we're choosing three Corvettes
gypsy and um the idea is to actually hit
the enemy heart sneak in and flank him
to the right and then basically take out
the tactical cruisers and it's Luke
cruisers that usually linger um behind
the fleet and let our dreadnought and
Italy cruiser take care of their heavier
ships so you can see that we are trying
to play out the strength of our classes
here go in fast and take the long route
surround the enemy team you're trying to
stay low so they don't see us and don't
call out the strategy to the rest of
their team I know is moving pretty fast
ahead so he's in the light covert and
tim is directing front of me also
equipped with a walk blink my My Lord is
actually a bit more um sneaky so I have
the medium cloak as my primary ability
of linger back like hold back a bit let
the others actually draw the attention
towards them and then hit them hard now
the warp ability gives me the
opportunity to go in really quickly as
you can see I'm further head and trying
to draw the fire on me on the right side
so I can start attacking their tactical
truth out there and it goes down already
so
that's a good start for a team
elimination and I see it definitely but
we took also a lot of damage so I'm now
focusing on the other two recruited him
I didn't see that tactically my nuclear
mine actually sitting there so detonated
and took out all three of us and there
was a good trade for the sniper for the
analytic ruler he went down but he took
three of our guys as you can see Peters
jumping back into the game as a fighter
jet with anal and me in front of him so
one good thing about dying at the same
time is that now we can really team up
as file address and coordinate well you
can see that there's quickly a target
called out with a fist as Alex so the
three of us focus on him draw the fire
on him and so light covet doesn't take
too much damage but is usually pretty
quick in this case you get stuck between
the three of us and we are all focusing
on fire at the same time and Alex goes
down here you can see even though we
lost our captive trip there's still
something useful we can do as long as we
go to latest a change here so we quickly
the next target is called out again we
have been focusing on the smaller and
ships with left hands so letting the
dreadknots light but focusing on the
Otori cruiser he knows his way he has
the anti-missile laser catching our
missiles which is already a big chunk of
earth damage he would have taken out in
the upper right you can see that all
three fighters entertainment I are all
actually like focusing in on Nathan
India to lose and if we all focus on
fire actually it is a lot of damage that
English out at the same time I think
that was a really good first run for our
fighter I'm outta here there's a fighter
jet behind me in
yeah he saw that and I was a revenge
first but that gives us a really nice
view of our heavy threat not equipped
with a fighter launching base an ability
that we haven't talked about that a lot
that will hopefully get the chance to
talk about more in the future so you see
the enemy dreadnought lingering there
actually waiting for us to be taking out
our too late so our trade knife went
down we couldn't turn it around although
we had low ourselves pretty well with
the fighter jets but first round over
and actually where we lost this round I
think this is a good opportunity to
switch our gears a bit and I'd really
like to go a bit more defensive such
time since we were really aggressive in
the first round yeah more firepower more
standing power and free dreadknots we'd
read more else do you have to say so
three dreadnoughts one tactical cruiser
to keep us up and running really nice
formation that we chose here so the
technical cruiser is enough a nested
between the three dreadknots taking us
as mobile cover and on top of that we
have an artillery cruiser that's holding
back a bit giving us firepower Oh
already the first enemy showing his ship
it's a light scout it's probably just
pointing out us as targets to his team
so they know what's going on and he's
gone already but as you can see yes as
you can see we used the opportunity to
dish out a few rockets there so to
demonstrate in other words i'm using
rockets so there's a massive amount of
giant rockets going over there hunting
the corvette and if it doesn't actually
have rocket defense or Dodgers behind
cover that's gonna it will definitely
keep us keep him occupied for is it yeah
they're happy yeah so idea is to
actually flank the enemy to the left
some keep formation and figure out who's
over there you can see that in the on
the mini-map on the upper right there's
an tactical cruiser and I think to the
left there was a destroyer coming up
another tackle cruiser yes soon as the
enemy fire says weapons he gets reviewed
on our radar and so that's
also a strategic question went to fire
at what if you want to keep low profile
destroyer to the lower left first it
seems like we are deciding to go for
that one but then starting to unload on
taboos and desert lights drat not
actually moving in pushing aggressively
against our and is pulling our attention
really well you can see how we shifted
our focus from the destroyer on the left
side to the light right not here as a
lot of rockets coming in forum is a lot
of damage dished out at the very short
as you can see there's to greet green
beans so there's two tactical cruisers
actually supporting the light retina
which makes it almost impossible for us
to shoot him down and the enemy's team
tactic really paid off we are focusing
on our fire on the light red not here
but we are unable to actually take him
down because he's being supported by a
heavy tactic loser and a medium tech
who's at the same time so shifting at
attention trying to either destroy the
check recruiter or at least pushing
behind cover so breaking line of sight
to the light red not even though we were
so well structured at the beginning you
can see that the Justin's situation drew
us apart and kind of took away the
strength of our setup so you can see
that everyone is scattered around
looking for a good target to attack and
the situation Peter uses to just blink
away and just cool down a bit and see
what's actually going on here i was
going for Nathan but Nathan already
dodged putting the energy to the engines
getting into the fight actually have the
option here to dish out a bit of damage
while he's dodging behind the rock
formation and yeah here you can see the
fight is actually focusing on the other
side there's our fighter jets and they
are in a really nice formation to attack
us here we have to regroup and actually
refocus our efforts to take out the
enemy team again light threat not drive
alive still alive still with the
tactical crews are here
using the broadside and missiles so but
we have our habit ratna to actually all
be there so if we all focus our efforts
on to him but there goes our tactical
cruiser so now we are three dreadknots
no tactical cruiser so only damage no
repair own so this is going to be tricky
so they are still set up with two
tactical cruisers so we have to get them
down at some point there's no other way
yeah but now all the journals are
focusing on Peter and we actually
managed to take him down the tactic
include azure there below that is a
destroyer so I decide to jump in and
focus on the technical crews are first
that seems to be going pretty okay since
the other type of user is currently
distracted or no X is actually
supporting you see how have you drop it
over there pulls a lot of attention from
the enemy T which gives you the
opportunity to deal some damage to the
tactical foolin covet whizzing by but my
sheets go up so I block the worst damage
from that covet and my rock is actually
nice damage and the broadside on top of
that with the secondary weapon that is
designed to do a lot of damage at short
to medium-range so the tackle cruiser
goes down I think the Scouters dude
there is doing a really good job there
whizzing by keeping the whole model
destroying the players and still doing
damage and although our heavy is
actually focused on the tactical cruiser
who was supporting the destroyer here
and he actually was forced to get out of
the battle you can see here that the
Corvette on the mini-map is going to the
right and I'm activating my broadside
actually forcing him to jumping in and
getting out without doing too much
damage those gives you the opportunity
to take off this destroyer yeah
finally so the story goes down but we
lost our heavy dreadnought as well so it
so now it's down to the covert yeah now
it's down to a lot of fighter jets a
Corvette and a heavy dreadnought so
let's see who's fighters do a better job
definitely so the chabad is actually
joining the fight being a lot quicker
than i am going towards my direction
here so I pull up my shield since a lot
of fighter jets are unloading towards me
I chose to jump but since I jump he gets
into my range and I have the option to
actually activate the broadside which
hit him really hard I'm far away from
the from the Quebec now but since my
fighter jets are around i can call out
the target and let them finish the job
and the corvette goes down and the match
is over so we are finishing this at 11
21 actually usually team elimination is
best of three but this will take a
little bit too long and after two such
with matches we're going to finish this
session of team elimination oh yes I
hope you really like this please leave
us your comments so that we can react to
it and we'll show you more of different
game modes and different shapes and
different abilities well as soon